건물이 기존 규모보다 더 커 보이는
효과를 줄 수 있도록
[음악]
적용했습니다 안녕하세요 bsn 건축사
사무소 김준석 소장입니다 오늘은
최근에 저희가 설계한 건물 앞에 나와
있습니다 리모델링을 한 프로젝트인데
어떤 식으로 디자인 포인트를 주었는지
또 어떤 요소들에 대해서 변경을
했는지 간략하게 소개해 드리도록
하겠습니다 리모델링 관련 꿀팁도
준비했으니 영상 끝까지 시청해 니다
사업 대상지는 강남구 신사동에
위치하고 있으며 대지면적 약 77평
건물의 연면적은 한 240평 정도
되는 규모입니다 지하 1층부터 지상
5층까지 규모로 이루어져 있고요
기존의 용적률이 초과되어 있는
건물이었기 때문에 신축보다는
리모델링으로 개발 방향을 결정했습니다
주요 변경 사항으로는 외관 디자인에
대한 변경과 승강계 교체 내부 공용
공간에 대한 공간 재구성이 있었습니다
사업대상 주변으로는 신축과
리모델링되는 건물들이 많이 있는데
여러 종류의 외부 마감 재료와
디자인들이
홍제어린이집
건물의 매스감을 강조해 주기 위해서
가벽을 이용해서 건물의 수직성을
표현했는데요이 수직성 강조하다 보면은
건물이 자칫 단조로워 보일 수가
있습니다 그래서 알루미늄 시트를
이용해서 건물의 입면을 좀 분할을
하였고 분인 된 입면과 창호에 대한
비율을 조정함으로써 인면 자체로도
리듬감을 가질 수 있도록 디자인을 할
때 고려를 했었습니다 마감 재료가
벽돌을 하나하나 쌓아서 만드는
방식인데요 벽돌의 시공 품질에 따라서
건물의 이제 입면에 대한 느낌이 많이
달라질 수 있습니다 모서리에 위치해
있는 돼지다 보니 도로의 이면이 많이
노출이 되었고 접하고 있는 도로가 좀
넓어서 사실 가로에서 봤을 때도 우리
건물이 많이 노출되는 그런
상황이었습니다 가로에서 경관성 을
고려해서 건물의 후면부까지 디자인을
통일시켜서 적용을 한 그런 사례입니다
1층의 경우 도로 면에서 바로 내부
공간으로 진입할 수 있는 출입구가
계획되어 있었기 때문에 건물에 대한
주출입구의 입구성이 필요했습니다 입구
부분은 게이트 형태의 디자인을 적용을
해서 입구성 확보해 주었고 건물의 최
상단부에는 알루미늄 루버를 수직적으로
계획을 해서 어 건물의 주된 포인트가
될 수 있도록 적용을 했습니다
최근들어 저희가 이제 많이 적용하고
있는 이제 설계 기법 중에 하 인데
옥상 부분의 가격을 조금 더 높게
시공을 해서 건물이 기존 규모보다 더
커 보이는 효과를 줄 수 있도록
적용했습니다 기존 건물의 계단이 현행
법규에 맞지 않아서 너비와 높이가
확보돼 있지 않은 상황이었습니다
그래서 저층부의 계단을 철거를 한
후에 신설을 하였고 계단과 엘리베이터
위치에 맞도록 화장실을 다시 재구성을
해 줬습니다이 화장실의 위치는 전용
공간 내부에 포함되는 경우도 있고
공용 공간에서 바로 접근이가
가능하도록 공용 공간에 포함되는
경우도 있는데 본 프로젝트에서는 공용
공간에서 접근할 수 있도록 배치를
하였습니다 층마다 다른 구조로 이제
화장실들이 배치가 됨으로써 설비
배관에 대한 시공이 굉장히
중요했는데요 그런 부분들도 화장실
천장속 공간을 이용해서 깔끔하게
처리를 하였습니다 내부 공간에는
기둥이 간섭되지 않도록 추가적으로
구조 보강을 최소화 하였고요 구조
보강이 되는 부분을 최소화하기 위해
천장에 구조 보강을 하였고 공간
내부에는 별도의 보강이 설치되지
않도록 구조 설계를 계획했습니다 다른
프로젝트하고 조금 차별화 됐던 점은
내부 마감에 굉장히 좀 많이 신경을
썼던 프로젝트였습니다 계단실과
엘리베이터 홀에는 인테리어 마감을
적용해서 추 임차인들이 건물을 사용할
시에 별도의 인테리어 공사를 하지
않아도 될 수 있도록 건축 공사에서
미리 반영을 하였습니다 인테리어
마감을 적용을 했기 때문에 건축
공사보다 조금 더 마감의 퀄리티가
많이 향상되었고 더 분에 이제 건물이
조금 더 깔끔하고 깨끗하게 보일 수
있는 효과를 가지고 왔습니다 이번
프로젝트 같은 경우에 용적률이 초과돼
있는 건물이었기 때문에 리모델링으로
개발하는게 좋은 방향이었고 리모델링을
할 때 변경할 수 있는 부분들에
대해서 말씀을 드리자면 도로 사선은
이제 패이 되었기 때문에 도로 사선
제한을 받았던 부분들은 외관 디자인에
대한 변경이 가능해집니다 그렇기
때문에 기존에 이제 경상 형태의
지붕을 가지고 있었던 건물들의 디자인
변경을 원하신다면 도로 사선 제한 의
간섭이 돼 있는지 꼭 체크해 보셔야
될 필요가 있고요 정복 1조 사선
제한 같은 경우에도 정복 방향으로만
일조 사선 제한을 받기 때문에 실제로
일조 사선 제한에 대한 범위를 확인을
해 보면 수직적으로 가격이나
구조물들을 설치할 수 있는 여유
공간이 나올 수가 있습니다 이런
내용들을 사전에 확인을 하셔서
설계하는 단계에서 건물의 디자인에
적용을 해 보시는 것도 좋은 방법이
될 것 같습니다 앞서 소개해 드린
것처럼 내부 공간에 대한 활용성이
매우 중요하기 때문에 구조 보강을 좀
최소화하는 것들이 중요한데요 이런
방법들도 여러 가지의 구조 설계
기법으로 최소화하는 방법들을 찾아갈
수가 있습니다 철골 기둥과 철골 보를
설치하는 거 외에 천장에 탄소 섬유
보강을 한다든지 철판 보강을 하는
방법 등을 찾아서 내부 공간을 조금
더 효율적으로 사용할 수 있는 방법을
찾을 수도 있습니다 말씀드린 내용을
기억하시고 적용하신면 리모델링할 때
좋은 팁이 될 거 같습니다 오늘은
최근 저희가 설계한 건물에 와서 건물
디자인에 대한 특징 내부 공간에 대한
구성 그고 또 변경 사항들에 대해서
말씀드렸는데요 저희가 또 신축과
리모델링 프로젝트들을 많이 진행하고
있으니 다음번에는 또 다른 현장에서
건물 소개해 드리는 기회를 갖도록
하겠습니다이 영상이 마음에 드셨다면
구독과 좋아요 부탁드립니다 감사합니다
[음악]